Fox News host Chris Wallace has enraged
the Fox News audience by sort of
piercing their narrative about no
collusion no obstruction the entire
molar probe was a witch hunt started
with a bogus bogus dossier talking point
we've debated before on the show how
much value there is in having these
occasional voices of reason on Fox News
and the argument usually goes on the one
hand it's good when Chris Wallace or
Shep Smith or whoever say something
that's just kind of an uncontroversial
truth in in most of the world on fox
news because it will kind of awaken
their audience to the reality that there
are other perspectives on what the Trump
administration and is doing and that's a
good thing the counter-argument is that
when you have occasionally Shep Smith or
Chris Wallace say some grain of truth on
Fox News it kind of provides cover to
Fox News to be able to say we're fair
and balanced do we have a diversity of
views we have Chris Wallace and Shep
Smith see we're doing it were fair and
balanced and the reality is that even
when Chris Wallace or Shep Smith say
some basic truth about the Trump
administration they're not challenging
the sort of propaganda corporate media
status quo and may even help to sort of
reinforce it but my position
historically has been I think it's a net
positive it's a net positive despite
being maybe a small one - occasionally
pierce the narrative of Fox News viewers
with someone there who will tell some
minor truth so that gets us to Chris
Wallace over the weekend Chris Wallace
said something that is obviously true
and undeniable at this point but it has
thrown the Fox News audience into a rage
Wallace said that when Rush Limbaugh was
recently interviewed on Fox News about
the end of the Moller probe Rush
Limbaugh said that the entire thing
started with that phony dossier written
by Christopher Steele the British X
British intelligence agency that has
been repeated a bunch of times now it's
already been widely debunked Rush
Limbaugh said it and Chris Wallace
simply said that's not true
and it has thrown Fox News viewers into
a rage
take a look you're exactly right when
the report comes out because
particularly on obstruction it's not a
clean bill of health you know it did bar
ended up saying he didn't think there
was a basis for prosecution but exactly
as you point out they're gonna be able
to say well you know he did this or that
this happened and there was only one
other point I do want to beg and I know
this is gonna drive some of our viewers
nuts the Trump investigation did not
start with the FISA warrant and Carter
page and even the dossier it started in
June in July of 2016 when George
papadopolis had spoken to a Russian
agent and spoke to an Australian
diplomat and said he had heard that they
had information on dirt on Hillary
Clinton that's when the investigation
started so it wasn't October it was in
September it was in July and was George
papadopolis not to say that the vasa
were just a legitimate basis let me just
finish the legitimate basis for inquiry
but that is not where the investigation
started it's funny that Chris Wallace he
knows in advance that the Fox News
audience is so rabid and disconnected
from reality that he says he knows it's
going to drive their audience nuts for
him to say something so uncontroversial
and obviously truths it's like he gave
him a trigger warning I'm about to tell
the truth Chris Wallace announces and
it's going to trigger the Fox News
audience the Trump is narrative so I'm
gonna warn you that I'm about to tell
the truth Wallace says the investigation
actually started when Trump associates
spoke to Russians about the 2016
election that's true and what a lot of
people are missing about this entire
narrative if you didn't know that there
were people claiming the whole thing
started with a FISA warrant then I envy
you I mean I wish I didn't know that
this is something people were saying but
investigations don't start with FISA
warrants right they keep repeating this
idea but a FISA warrant is an
investigative technique or a mechanism
investigations don't start with FISA
warrants FISA warrants are issued for
investigations that
already stand on their own and not
surprisingly pat the smears of Chris
Wallace immediately starred for just
telling uncontroversial truths to the
audience and you gotta love what Bill
Hemmer did there which is just to
completely try to shut down Chris
Wallace make sure that what Chris
Wallace had to say was not going to get
out there on the airwaves you got the
sense that Bill Hemmer knew that people
up at the Fox News executive offices and
people watching Fox News back home we're
not going to like what Chris Wallace had
to say there yeah Bill Hemmer couldn't
resist he said and bet I like when chris
wallace actually says hey let me let me
finish let me finish this completely
mild milquetoast defense of just one
element of all of the crazy things that
rush limbaugh tried to say so this this
is why i question the kind of real value
of these occasional voices of reason on
Fox because in the same segment Wallace
still does go along with a bunch of
nonsense related to the bar report
without questioning it
but just this like one little point he
questions and Bill Hemmer doesn't like
it and the Fox News audience doesn't
like it so I guess we can say it's good
in general that at least he corrected
one point but big picture Chris Wallace
is part of the apparatus and we can't
really expect any serious critique of
the status quo from him or whoever else
there is on Fox News let me know what
you think I think it's a mild net
positive to have him there every once in
a while saying something that's true